[Music]
president trump's decision
that day alone saved countless american
lives
and it allowed us to stand up the
largest national mobilization since
world war
[Applause]
millions of medical supplies to our
incredible doctors and nurses
we've developed medicines that are
literally saving lives
as we stand here today we're on track to
have the first safe and effective corona
virus
vaccine before the end of this
[Applause]
the first year i'll move you all down by
the outpouring of prayers and support
for both of them over this past week i
spoke to the president this morning
back to the white house and
[Applause]
the medical care that they received the
medicines that they received
all a part of the national response that
we've made available
people all across this country and the
outpouring of concern
for our president our first lady was
emblematic of the love and the concern
and care that the american people have
shown to neighbors and family members
and friends
absolutely could you join me in just
thanking all of the amazing healthcare
workers who served our nations
and we're opening up america again
for families and for businesses they
actually literally saved 50 million jobs
we've lost 22 million jobs at the height
of this pandemic
we've already added 11.6 million
jobs back to work including 115
000 people back to work right here
[Applause]
the american comeback is on we're
opening up america
and we're opening up american schools
[Music]
rapid point-of-care tests to states
across the country to get our schools
open to keep our schools open and keep
our kids
[Applause]
[Music]
we're coming to a time for choosing
taxes by four trillion dollars
on certain americans but joe biden said
twice in the debate last week
that on day one he was going to repeal
the trump tax cuts
and the truth of the matter is president
donald trump cut taxes across the board
it gave middle-class families a 2 000
tax break
it increased income and
wages by 4 000 dollars
taxes for the middle class for four more
years
[Applause]
to bury our economy under an avalanche
of red tape
including his own version of the green
new deal
which is a whole lot like aoc's version
of the green new year
president trump he's actually
he's actually overseen the largest
investment in public lands
in our national parks in american
history the cleanest air
and land in our history the cleanest
water
in the world and we cut federal red tape
and unleashed american energy all at the
same time
[Applause]
[Music]
free lawyers and free health care for
illegal immigrants
president donald trump he kept the
promises he made to the people of nevada
we had record investments in border
security mexico is doing more to secure
their southern border and ours than ever
before
and we've already built more than 300
miles
of that border wall on the southern
border of the united states
[Applause]
we're going to build it all
[Applause]
and when it comes to jobs and trade the
contrast couldn't be more clear
under joe biden just 47 years in
washington dc we saw deals like
nafta you know in the wake of nafta
being signed into law in 1995
60 000 factories closed and many of
those jobs
went south of the border and overseas
never lifted a finger to reform nafta
but thanks to the man who wrote the deal
america got a better deal
nafta is gone and the usmca is here
actually said it was a positive
development to see the rise of china
literally behalf of our international
trade deficit from day one
president donald trump puts china on
notice
that the era of economic surrender is
over
until they open their markets respect
american private property rights
and put american jobs in american
workers
[Music]
as i said earlier it's also been about
our most cherished values
joe biden donald harris and the
democratic party
actually support late term abortion and
john wants to
use taxpayer dollars to pay for abortion
all the way up to the moment of birth
i'll tell you i couldn't be more proud
to serve as vice president to a
president who stands without apology for
the sanctity of human life
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and we will keep standing for life for
four
more years
now when you look at their agenda
i said this in fort mchenry
joe biden would be nothing more than a
trojan horse
for the radical left now joe biden has
said that democracy is on the ballot
on november 3rd well i think our
economic recovery is on the ballot law
and order are on the back
but i also think there are things much
more foundation
that's more fundamental to our country
this election i don't think nevada i
don't think it's going to be whether
whether america ends up more republican
or more democrat
whether we end up more liberal or more
conservative more red or more blue
i think the choice in this election is
whether america remains america
our faith and family and freedom and
patriotism and the american flag and the
constitution of the united states
and whether we're going to abandon that
now
and allow the wrath of the democratic
party to take our nation somewhere it's
never been before
so let me say today to all of you
standing here in the blazing sun on the
back
for our freedom for all the ideals that
have always made
america great and are making america
great again we need to decide right here
and right now that joe biden will never
be
president of the united states for four
more you know you're right four more
years means more jobs
four more years needs more judges four
more years means more support for our
troops
and law enforcement and it's going to
take at least four of our years to train
that job
and we've got to be very close friends
i've seen him when the cameras are off
and i'll tell you what there's never
been a day gone by when president donald
trump has
gotten up and fought to keep the
promises that he made to the people
of nevada now it's our turn to fight for
[Applause]
him
[Applause]
[Applause]
i want you to keep voicing your support
talk to your neighbors and
friends at work and worship about all
that we've done in the last three years
about the way this
president has led us through this
challenging year
and all that we have yet to do we'll
tell the american people that the choice
we face and remind the american people
the choices in their hands
[Music]
and when you do have faith have faith
you know i honestly believe a careful
study of american history shows every
time the american people have been given
a clear choice
between a future more freedom and less
freedom
they choose more freedom every single
[Applause]
time
in the next 26 days i encourage you to
do that too
i truly do
[Applause]
seems like it looks like there's more
that divides us in america
and unites us but i've traveled all
across this country
over the last three and a half years and
i can tell you
there will always be more that unites
the people
of this great nation than could ever
divide us and shift among those things
so if you're a person of faith i
encourage you to explain those ancient
words
the americans have come to through much
more challenging times than we could
even imagine
that if it are called by is name will
humble themselves and pray
he'll do like he's always done in the
long and storied history of this country
he'll hear from heaven and he'll heal
this land
under god indivisible with liberty
and justice
[Applause]
thank you for this especially
really great to be in nevada but karen
and i have a plane to catch
we're headed to arizona and then we're
back to washington d.c
i guarantee you president donald trump
is going to be back on the campaign
trail before you know it we're going to
[Applause]
every day between now and november 3rd
we're going to make nevada
and america stronger than ever before
we're going to make nevada and america
more prosperous than ever before
and regina martian and big dan
vote on her in a new republican majority
in the united states house of
representatives with a renewed
republican majority
in the united states senate and with
president donald trump
in the white house for four more years
and with god's help we will make
america great again
[Applause]
thank you very much
[Music]
uh